M it's God
it's it's
God it's
God what's
what's all right so let's go ahead can't
throwback that's that UK can't throwback
baby
right what's up brother what's up how
you doing is is there anything that you
disagree with on any of these I got oh
is it on no I second this one Jesus Is
God Jesus Is God you disagree with that
one yeah okay what what what's your
religious belief uh Islam Islam you're
Muslim alhamdulillah all right we're
good to go okay so you're Muslim so you
don't believe Jesus God all right why is
that because he the our Prophet beloved
Prophet upon him okay is it because this
what the Quran says yeah okay so you
believe he's a prophet you believe he's
a messiah as well oh yeah and what what
do you think Messiah means because he's
the only one who Messiah right the
Messiah is going
to the Messiah so the the word Messiah
means anointed one and so the Messiah
has a specific mission right and he has
a specific identity but unfortunately
the Quran doesn't tell us what that is
right so it says yes Jesus is a prophet
he's a messenger of God right he came he
was born of a virgin but it doesn't tell
us why he's the Messiah it just why he
the Messiah because the end of the he's
he's going to fight is the Antichrist
he's going to come to the Earth okay
he's coming back he's the second coming
this is something we believe to as
Christians we believe the same thing
says directly says the Quran is about
his second coming and he's going to save
us from the from from the Antichrist
right now here's my question to you then
with that okay if what if what makes him
the Messiah is that he's going to come
back how was anybody supposed to know he
was the Messiah when he was here cuz
that's way in the end times right
because it's the God's books bible Torah
There It Is Gospel Quran so before
before the Quran came we would have to
have some indication that yes he's the
Messiah right yeah so how how would we
know because of the Bible gospel say
that again yeah Bible of gospel man hey
give him a round of applause you're
absolutely right I got to shake your
hand on that but but you're right now
here's the interesting thing when we
look at what the Bible says about the
Messiah this is what it tells us one it
tells us one that he's supposed to be
born of a virgin this is Isaiah the
prophet Isaiah 7:14 it says the Lord is
going to give you a sign and the Virgin
shall give birth to a son and shall call
his name Emmanuel you know what Emanuel
means no we got a he we got a Hebrew
speaker here what does uel means God
With Us it means so it means god with us
so it tells us that the one who's going
to be born of a virgin who's going to
come in the flesh is actually God
himself coming in the flesh So when you
say Jesus is the Messiah that's who
you're saying he is God who came with us
in the flesh
you know what I'm saying so that that's
why I'm saying if you know what Messiah
means then you you have a problem with
Islam because Islam as you're right
Islam says that Jesus is just a
messenger right he's no more than a
prophet of God but it also calls him the
Messiah but by calling him the Messiah
it literally means that he is God Who
Came In the Flesh make sense is the so
so the Hebrew in Isaiah 9 says that he's
Pelle elgore El gior is literally Mighty
God that's clearly what it means that
the son to be born with us will be
Mighty God but I have a question did
Jesus pray right peace be upon yeah he
communicated with his father Yes okay
but who is his father is God so so this
is what the Bible teaches so the Bible
teaches that God is infinite he's huge
right and his Essence is not like ours
right so like me and you we're one being
we're one human being one human person
right but God is Not Like Us the Bible
teaches that God in his Essence he's one
Divine being that consists of three
distinct person it's called the Trinity
so you have the Father the Son and the
Holy Spirit that share the same Divine
Ang what is the Angel Mel no no no it's
not the angel Gabriel see the holy
spirit is God's very own Spirit right is
is the very presence of God and power of
God right who's also personable he's not
an angel who is a created Messenger of
God right like Gabriel or Michael or
somebody like that so the Holy Spirit
he's Divine he's the very presence of
God himself right and so what we have
here is that you have the father son
Holy Spirit they've communic they've
communed with each other from eternity's
past they've always been together they
coexisted from eternity's past and
they've always fellowship with each
other so when the son comes down and
takes on human form he's still going to
continue that communication with the
father he's still going to talk to him
that's what prayer is is when you
communicate with the divine right so
that's what he's doing when he's here on
Earth he's not going to just stop
talking to the father and vice versa the
father's not going to stop talking to
the son so is the Jesus is submitted to
the God Jesus hum himself yeah he humbl
himself he submitted to the God yeah he
humbl himself so he's Muslim no he's not
no he's not Muslim but what is the trans
of the Muslim is like a submission to
the God we're going right into the good
segment he's going to try to win the
money now you want to win the money like
my question it's like what is like
submission to the god it's literally
translation of the like musliman it's
not nothing like it's Arabic word for
submission to the God is Muslim right
okay all right so so this is what I have
to say to that keep keep it on him cuz I
got my own so if if he said guys that
being a Muslim means to submit to God
now the question that we're going to ask
is which God because if I only one God
only one God yeah only one God all right
good that's good I believe that too but
let's say I believe that the one God
that I submitted to was a statute in my
closet Y Man y y' prophets back here y
some proph but let's say it's a statute
in my closet right and I submit to it
does that make me a Muslim if I say this
statue is the one God it's it's called
idolator it's called idolatry so I'm not
a Muslim right good so believing and
submitting to one God is not enough to
be a Muslim so it has to be a specific
God that you're talking about it's the
specific God which is the abrahamic
religion the god of Abraham Isaac and
Jacob okay so tell yeah I mean like
prophet Abraham like his religion
because we belong
to prophet Abraham peace be upon him he
brought it the monotheism no one yeah
one religion submission to the one God
got you okay and uh when Jesus prayed he
didn't pray he didn't say God right what
he say is father he said father yeah
father but in his language even there is
AB elim no no no he said ABA no ABA is
father but God you refer to in the Bible
if you read the Arabic Bible it says
like is Hebrew yeah that's Hebrew is the
same Allah it's the same
language there's a there's a little
mistake here so look look cuz you're
right he did call God God obviously but
he called God ABA as well which is which
is father so my question to you would be
is Allah the father of Jesus
no right Jesus I mean the God is not a
father right he's not father he didn't
give births he he's the exactly so so I
got you so the god that you're telling
me about is not a father he didn't give
birth to anybody doesn't be nor is he
begotten right he has no companion and
stuff like that right so that's the God
you have to submit to to be a Muslim
right so Jesus said that God when he
prayed is his father so he's praying to
his father and you're saying that Allah
is not his father so that would mean
that Jesus is not talking about Allah
right but Allah is Allah sir is Allah
it's mean is the translation is
literally it's been God my language I'm
usek we call but it doesn't mean
like we he pray for yeah every language
has for example we when you say
like you know language or Russian we say
like but I mean you know like but we
with the Allah is in Arabic right right
right it just means God but that's what
I'm saying like I know you're saying if
I if I if I call my statute Allah it
doesn't mean like I'm not worshiping God
not the true God right that's a false
god that's an idol so the true God
you're saying the true God the true God
is not a father right no okay I mean I'm
not saying the father I don't know like
what is the like what are you referring
to when you say father I'm ref the same
thing Jesus referred to Jesus said that
God is his father all all we creat of
the created by God but are you his son
are we all children of of God I mean I
I'm sure yeah we can like okay so let me
tell you you can't say that can refer
like this no you can't so look this is
chapter 19 are kids or whatever like
creation his creation but but you're now
you're sounding like a Christian I mean
it's all the sah like exactly we have to
believe all these God's book but it's
let me let me tell you why it's
different let me tell you why it's
different in the Quran it says that
Allah is not a father to anyone it says
that you can only be his slave he
literally said this is chapter Miriam
siriam Chapter 19: 93 he says there's
none in the heavens or the Earth that
can come to Allah except as a slave so
you can only be a servant to Allah not
his son so to say that you are his son
would be going against Islam that's what
I'm saying I mean the how do you refer
his son I'm his creature creation yeah
you're his creation but you're not his
son the god of the Bible the god of
Abraham says that you're not just my
creation but you're also my son as well
once you believe in the Messiah but
right and now you're just you're not a
son
yet and so when we if you believe in the
god of Abraham you got to believe in our
heavenly father who sent his son into
the world to give his life for you and
who is the heavenly father is God yes so
I believe God yeah but you don't you
don't believe do you believe he's your
heavenly father I
mean you can call different names you
can him do you believe he's your
heavenly father I mean the heavenly
father I can't believe it that he's my
heavenly father yeah why not then you
just left Islam No I can't leave Islam
but you can call the all the
interpretations you know like we can
call him Lord King Heavenly Father
Creator I mean Allah has 99 Names finish
it
y'all father ain't one bro father's not
one and this is why I say this okay cuz
you're right like you can you can refer
to him as king Lord right master all of
these things but Allah in the Quran is
very clear about the term father and
sunship he says don't even think about
it he says that the heavens and the
Earth crumble and they tremble at the
thought at the utterance that he is a
son that he has a son okay is the Bible
say right yes the
Bible Bible say by who by Moses and
Jesus no no I know but uh who sent the
Bible God did exactly so I have to
believe whatever God sent okay now very
good so what he said guys is he has to
believe the Bible because it's sent by
God and he has to believe what ever God
sent which is very true the Quran says
the same thing however there's the
problem okay cuz I'm we're not in this
dilemma as a Muslim you are because as a
Muslim you believe you have to believe
the Bible but the Bible contradicts the
Quran if the Bible is true then Islam is
false okay sir I have a question though
what is like God send so many books
right okay but the what he said last one
is going to be Quran because only book
I'm going to send is not going to be be
corrupted okay let me ask you this with
with that thought if God is sending
books right continuously they would all
have the same message right yeah they
will not contradict each other yes so if
he sent the last book which is the Quran
would the Quran contradict the previous
Scriptures it wouldn't right it wouldn't
it would line up yeah so how we how do
we know then if a book is false and not
from God if it's not consistent with the
books that came before because big books
before it get corrupted this way he s
the last book for the Quran not be
corrupted but then that goes against the
Quran again cuz the Quran says no one
can change the words of Allah okay no
one can change it but it's changed by
Kings and Priests all the way this so
they can change it no I mean of course
you can change it you can change the you
can bring the Quran and you can like
radicalize the Quran you know like so
when Allah says that none of his words
can be changed you're saying well
actually no Allah you're wrong no no
what is what I'm trying to say last book
what he s he can be corrupted but the
Quran doesn't say that the Quran says
the books are are true that it is true
yeah but the books are true but not the
human being because if I give you a book
right if you rewrite this book yeah
differently with yourself and you
telling that this is a true book this is
is being corrupted this why is the Quran
so people can lie the books are good but
people can lie about them okay now I
like so guys what he say is is that
people can distort people can lie but
the books are good which is very true I
can bring you the Bible right but I can
lie about what the Bible says you read
it and you could be like hey it doesn't
actually say that okay and people can do
the same with the Quran all right good
so now that's not what I'm talking about
what I'm I'm not talking about people
I'm talking about the books themselves
right people distort forget people if we
line up the books together right we see
that the the books they have the same
message if you bring original scripture
I'm sure they line his Quran is 100% but
we have those and we see that it doesn't
we have the Torah brother the Torah says
that God is our father who sends his son
the Messiah we have the gospel the inil
it says that God sent his son into the
world to save mankind who's the messiah
but then the Quran comes and says no
Allah's not a father and he doesn't have
a son and Jesus is not Lord this why is
is need you need to pray only one God
that's it you don't that's not enough
why Muslims they don't pray for the
prophet Muhammad which is one of the
biggest religion and one of the most
influenced person in the world why we
not like prostrate for him because of
they brought like such a powerly book in
Quran in Islam but he specifically give
us the direct instruction I'm not the
God I'm the messeng of the god and
listen the book what he said you know
what else he said he said I don't know
what my Lord is going to do with you or
with me that's what Muhammad says right
on the end on the last day he says I
don't know what my Lord is going to do
with me or with you
but what Jesus says is I don't know I
don't heard yeah that's in the Quran
okay I heard about I I didn't read I
guess it's all good but this what Jesus
says Jesus says if you believe on me
then you will have eternal life and I
will bring you to myself look at the
difference between the man of Muhammad
that you follow who doesn't know what
God's going to do with him but then
Jesus says you follow me I guarantee you
I promise you a room in my father's
house who would you rather go with it's
of course I'm going to go with Prophet
Muhammad on him yeah because he is he's
literally Quran saying this is
my if I believe the Bible gospel Angel
all these books right
Torah and this is exactly look you have
iPhone right yeah like iPhone 15 okay
and if you compare to iPhone 6 there has
like you get the new update update
update update and you get ultimate last
update so but we have so the Jewish
people preserve the text right so we
have toras that go back to the 1200s
that line up with the Dead Sea Scrolls
that were found in Kuman that line up so
we can show you those manuscripts that
line up with the same one we have today
did you know the Jewish people they
count the amount of letters in the Torah
to get to the middle letter so it's
exactly the same do you know we have
6,000 Greek manuscripts that go back to
the time of Jesus and it goes up to the
tens of thousands in translations in
Latin and Arabic and Syriac and all
these languages that show that we have
the same New Testament hundreds of years
before Muhammad so when were the texts
corrupted I don't know so if yeah so if
they're the same so if the texts are the
same and Muhammad came and taught
something contradictory to the text then
who's true the Bible of Muhammad is uh
is not the Quran is not the word of the
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him it's
the god of is the word of the god that
is no no no I think one dot he didn't
put by Prophet Muhammad I think you're
missing what I'm saying though what I'm
saying is that we have Greek manuscripts
and Hebrew manuscripts of the Torah and
the injil predating Muhammad by 700
years and even more we have a Greek
translation from 200 years before Jesus
that line up with the same Bible we have
today so like Avery asked you if we have
the Bible that says one thing and the
Quran says something different then the
Quran must be the book that's false I
mean whatever you think brother is in
the the our life we can answer for the
God you know whenever I can tell you
right now I'm not like
IM or like someone you know
yeah our life we can answer to the God
will you do this for me though will you
do can you make a commitment to me to
say you'll do it just yes or no will you
go back and double check if we have the
same Greek manuscripts and Hebrew Bible
that line up with today will you do
research on that and see if it's true I
mean I can do if you send me information
I will be no no no all you got to do is
go to Google look up the Dead Sea
Scrolls you can watch the streams God
logic apologetics look up Dead Sea
Scrolls look up the Greek manuscript
look up the Latin translation of the
Bible from the 400s look up the
translation of the Old Testament it's
all the same I have a question for you
how many times you wrote Quran hold on
hold on hold on hold on wait are you
going to do this for me no no I'm just I
don't think I need okay I don't think
you need to read the whole Quran to know
what it says I read the Quran myself
though read how many times uh just yeah
oh sorry you know because I never read
by myself like a full Quran this time
how many times you read yeah so I read
the Quran all the time read it fully one
but I continu is the contradictory part
for you about the Quran very good so
what so we asked guys what is the
contradictory Parts in the Quran that I
found that contradict the Bible right so
no not the contradict Bible or the
message oh about the whole like a book
what do you contradict about what's in
the Quran that contradicts the Quran no
yeah what is you not agree with the
Quran what do I not agree with the Quran
okay okay so what I don't agree with the
Quran is number one it says that Allah
is not a father to anyone okay okay the
the Torah and the gospel the both say
he's our father well what I'm trying to
say without without blocking your mind
with other books right you just what
about the Quran do I disagree with yeah
like if you read the without like
blocking your if I didn't know if I
didn't have the Bible if I just clean
mind you know if you sit and read what
you what you don't like about okay sure
sir okay so the one thing that I don't
like about the Quran one is is and we're
going to get it's going to get a little
touchy okay all right you clear with
that okay so I don't like how the Quran
um teaches uh its morality on how to
deal with non-muslims and also women so
how I'll give you I'll give you an
example so like for example you have
chapter
65:4 chapter 65:4 is talking about
divorce what you're supposed to do to
when you divorce your women right and so
when you divorce your women it gives you
three categories okay this is chapter 65
4 you got to take that no yeah okay so
654 it teaches that you're allowed to
marry and divorce prepubescent girls
girls who have not hit puberty yet
you're to what what is girls girls that
you haven't hit puber that haven't hit
puberty yet you're allowed to marry them
and then also divorce
you absolutely um where's where's life's
phone show I want to see that I got you
bro I want to see I didn't read that I
mean like I want to see I got got you
and and just to let you know just to let
you know that I'm not making it up I'm
going to show you I'll show you what the
scholar say about it okay all right so
the scholar show me the yeah I'm going
show you the Quran I'm going show you
the Quran first and then I'll show you
the commentary okay all right so he said
show them which is a good thing man he
said prove it man prove it cuz what what
do we do here y'all we just read we we
just read right that's that's all we do
right that's all we do we just read it's
going to get weird now all right so he
wants to know what what's my problem
with the Quan self all right so let's
let's pull up the
Quran all
[Music]
right little slow connection here it's
okay that's all right that's all right
let's go ahead and pull it up 654
sah guys let's give him another hand for
participating man he's awesome
all
right so here it is so this is chapter
65:4 okay it says and those who no
longer expect ministration among your
women right talking about divorce right
see T divorce that's the chapter name so
it's talking about divorcing your women
so when you divorce them if you don't um
so those who no longer expect
ministration among your women so they're
too old to ministrate right it says if
you doubt then their period is 3 months
so they have a 3-month waiting period
when you divorce them okay um then it
says and also those who have not
ministrate and for those who are
pregnant their term is until they give
birth right and whoever fears Allah he
will make for him of his matter it it
easy yeah but what is the previous
message what he saying about oh the
previous verse yeah uh it's just talking
about loading it up you have to read the
whole Surah for this you know not really
no yeah sir it's called Surah you know
you have to read the whole thing so you
like get you want to read verse
one hold a lot hold aot from the
beginning vers is long okay it's okay
read it I I want to read it we can't
like is
I got you I got you I got you understand
once he said previous though oh
Prophet it's it's verse one okay okay
want to verse one or ver no it's Quran
so top is the Arabic and the bottom is
the English okay okay okay yeah we good
so the first one yeah
okay oh my goodness we good man pray for
me only 55 verses Man only 55 verses we
good we just read right we really just
reading today we really just reading all
right you said it oh Prophet when you
divorce women divorce them uh for their
waiting period and keep count of the
waiting period and fear Allah your lord
do not turn them out of their houses nor
should they leave unless they are
committing a clear immorality like
fearing disob like if they might disobey
you or something like that no no what do
you disobey
if you fear Disobedience we know what
happens huh for example what do you mean
Disobedience this is the question it's
not like go bring me coffee this she
didn't and if she look at you wrong yeah
that's not the disobey okay okay that's
not the disobeying all right all right
all right so he says and whoever
transgresses the limits of Allah uh has
the limits of Allah has certainly
wronged himself you know not perhaps uh
Allah will bring about after the matter
all right so let's go verse
two man please they got paragraphs in
these verses and when they have
fulfilled their term either retain them
according to acceptable terms or part
with them according to acceptable terms
and bring to witness to just men from
among you and establish the testimony
for uh for Allah that is instructed to
whoever should believe in Allah in the
last day and whoever fears law he will
make for him a way out a way out all
right verse three and will provide for
him from where he does not expect and
whoever relies on upon Allah then he is
sufficient for him indeed Allah will
accomplish his purpose Allah has already
set for everything a decreed extent now
verse
four oh we got here and for those who no
longer expect to menray right those are
among your women if you doubt their
period is 3 months and those who have
not
been yeah their period their their
menstrual
cycle they ID um yeah so they have has a
period three months no no so when when
you get divorced when you divorce your
wife she uh if you've uh had sexual
intercourse with her she has to have a
3-month waiting period if she doesn't if
she's not sure if she's pregnant so
before she moves on to the next man
right tell him tell him what's the name
of the Surah in Arabic it's t divorce
all divorce so that's what the context
is so so for the so for uh the older
women who no longer expect them men
State their waiting period is 3 months
when they get divorced and now it's also
the same for the girls who have not
minated it says and those who have not
minated so girls who have not minated
they have the same waiting period no he
didn't say girls he's talking about your
vies there right now because it's
divorce but your you know you don't
divorce is your when you see the girls
it's Al it's your wife there's no girls
your your wife is a it could be a girl
or a girl you lose your virginity you're
not girl anymore you're woman this is
the thing even so okay I got you so if
you're when it comes to this it talks it
says those who have not menrad right
okay okay so the type of woman who had
the girl no no no no no look and no read
from here if you die period three months
and those who no longer expect
ministration among your women if you
doubt then their period is 3
months and those who have not ministr
that mean it's pregnant no it doesn't
mean what yeah if you don't ministrate
you pregnant no no brother look it
already IT addresses the pregnant and so
the next part is and for those who are
pregnant so before they're not pregnant
exactly what he's saying look and for
those to the translations the
translation sometimes no no yeah look
look it's okay the
Arabic those who have not administrated
yeah who have
administrated if if you wait three
periods right no they no they have the
same period they have the same 3mon
period okay yeah saying like if you
ministrate in 3 months period which is
me you're not pregnant when you not
Minister you not you pregn correct
correct correct so look so look so what
it says so you're you're you're close
but you're just missing the point so
first category are the women who are too
old to ministrate so they don't they
know they don't expect to ministrate
anymore so that's why they have a
waiting period to make sure they're not
pregnant okay so they don't know if
they're pregnant or not they don't even
know if they're going to get a period
okay so that's category one category two
are the ones who have not minated so
they haven't minated at all okay so they
also have a three-month waiting period
when they get divorced to make sure
they're not pregnant because they
haven't gotten a period before at all
they haven't gotten a menstrual cycle so
how you look that is the you can marry
only that that period of life let let's
say 2,000 years ago they they was a rule
you have to mared the girl only after
when they get their period but but
that's not true though it's called this
why is called I I hear what you're
saying what's up what's up brother but
that's but that's not what it says here
it says you're allowed to marry
even before they about the divorce sir
right so if they're divorcing them
before they ministr that means that they
married them before they ministrate you
can't marry the before the start
ministration then how are they how are
they divorcing girls who haven't
administrated yet if you can't marry
them because they saying make sure
they're not pregnant if you not
ministrate you pregnant okay
so I don't I don't know how we can
communicate this dude it says if you
doubt those who have no longer no longer
expect to menray okay so those are the
older women right no no no no if you no
longer expect to menray what kind of
woman are you if you not no me which is
mean it's me you're
pregnant brother it's mean you're
pregnant then why are they waiting 3
months because if you're not
uh pregnant you're going to ministrate
but you're saying they're already
pregnant this is the second part this is
the second part you look you have to
wait 3 months would you like to see what
a scholar says look at listen to me like
let me explain okay you did you're not
lining up with the B no I'm going to
line up with your we'll see okay it's
saying how they know back in the day
okay you have to wait 3 months
ministration period okay if you get 3
months period you make sure you know
she's not pregnant okay if she has a 3
month minist so that means before her
3mon period she hasn't administrated
no no no you married you want a divorce
this is all about the wife it's not
about the girls or like it's about the
wife how you want to make a divorce they
is saying if you want to give a divorce
make sure she's going to ministrate
three months okay after she three month
ministration you can give her divorce if
she's not getting administrated that
mean she's pregnant you can't give her
divorce no you can even still give a
divorce say so look let me just show let
me just show you cuz
no no cuz we already we're going to read
it over and over again it doesn't matter
okay so you ready so it says and for
those who are pregnant so you can
divorce the woman that's pregnant what
he say no but read it what he says if
and and for those who are pregnant their
term is until they give birth you have
to let them go when they give they can
move on when they give
birth you can divorce a pregnant woman
no you can't you have to take care of it
says until the and for those who no
longer expect ministration when you're
divorcing them among your women if you
doubt their period is 3 months and for
those who don't ministrate and for those
who don't ministrate and for those who
are pregnant all in the context of
divorce their waiting period is until
they give birth that's when you can let
them go and they move on to another man
no not the is giving e sorry what I'm
trying to say is saying you can't give a
divorce after they give the until they
give the birth saying so let's see what
the scholars say let me just show you so
that let me just show you what the
Muslim Scholars say you say you're not
IM I'm an IM let's see what the scholar
say and let's say if they agree with you
or me okay all right so this is I big
Sunni scholar one of the biggest ones
okay he
sayses all are the exalted clarifies the
waiting period of the woman in
menopause and that is the one whose
ministration has stopped due to her
older age right her ID a waiting period
is 3 months instead of the three monthly
Cycles so they're not looking for a
period so instead of having a period the
minstry cycle you just wait 3 months
just to make sure you're not pregnant
right so he says um instead of the three
monthly cycles for those who ministrate
which is based on chap 2:
228 the same for the
young who have not reached the years of
ministration their Ida is 3 months like
those in minapa this is the meaning of
his saying and for those who have no
courses so this is a scholar ier who
literally say first first category older
women second category is the young girls
this this is what I'm trying to say said
you can inter inter interpret any kind
of like all brother all the SCH say the
same thing all of them like uh again I
don't know said I'm not arguing with
this part but what I'm trying to say you
can interpret uh ever you want okay you
know what I mean okay can I show you my
second problem can I show you my second
problem all right so my second problem
is um is the ability to hit your wife I
don't believe that you should be able to
hit your wife under any circumstances if
your life is not in danger you know what
I'm saying do you agree with that of
course I okay good so the Quran says
that if you fear Disobedience from them
then you can admonish them right check
them first push the chest well no no not
push the chest here that's this is what
it's say push it push it in the chest
well no it says beat them or strike no
it didn't say beat okay show me okay I
got you
show all right this my second
issue makes me happy Christian Warriors
out here all right so men are in charge
of women right women are uh men are in
charge of women by right of what Allah
has given one over the other and what
they spend from their wealth all right
so righteous women are devoutly obedient
guarding in their husband's absence what
Allah would have them guard but those
whom you fear arrogance hold on I got to
sneeze all right it left me bless you
it's gone now Satan was in my nose I
think um but those of you who you fear
arrogance really the word is
Disobedience advise them forsake them in
bed and stri
them but if they obey you seek no means
against them indeed Allah is ever
exalted and Grand what is the what is
the Bible says about the heting the
woman I seen the same chapter like like
I'm glad you asked what what does the
Bible say so he ask guys what does the
Bible say when it comes to husbands
treating their wives so the Bible I mean
like the the bible really say you have
to hit your nowhere no nowhere does the
bible nowhere does the bible ever say
this
get get the get the wait what did J J
say get that is that Bible is that Bible
you not speaking Bible tonight that
ain't Bible I want the verse book
chapter verse book chapter verse where
tell a man to hit his wife
got again and if you're if you're real
real Muslim you can't hit your VI
because the
mother the the you can't hit your wife
because the paradise God Prophet
M says paradise and the feet of your
mothers you know this is this why
talking to the my brother but mham
Muhammad says you can beat your
wives mamad says
it it's okay guys hold on he's asking
where does Muhammad say so so I'm
showing Allah that Allah says you can
beat your wives and then I'm going to
show you that Muhammad also says yeah go
ahead beat them wow wow wow I'll show
you scure that God says he's against the
beating see right here it says yet yet
he say wherefore because the Lord have
been witness between thee and the wife
of thy youth against whom thou has dealt
treacherously yet she is thy companion
and thy wife and I Covenant and he goes
to say continuously about the treachery
is that it was it was the abuse of the
wife so God through Malachi is actually
rebuking the Jews at that time for how
they were covering the women the
beatings that they were giving them
chasing them and that they were coming
to God's altar with tears so God was
grieved with this abuse but Islam they
they recommend that that's like that's
the doctrine because they want control
they're angry that's tough we not angry
s you look more Angry than me you know
just really quickly the reason why
Muhammad had that Doctrine cuz Satan put
it in his heart because they blame wom
for the fault you see committed she she
gave to Adam there's like an animosity
towards women for this CRI no it's
look it's I don't know what do you see I
know your Western TV saying the Muslims
hitting the wife believe me
my niece was married to a Muslim my
niece was married to a Muslim I grew up
around him for 5 years and I watched him
hit his sister beat his sister and abuse
my niece and he justify himself by the
doctrine by that Doctrine the what do
you think white white people they don't
hit their wife if they do they
on they can be listen they can be called
Christians they can be called Christians
all they want but if you find a
Christian man beating his wife he's not
a Christian he's covering himself
exactly exactly the same
same Islam that is a a fundamental
Doctrine that's taught in the in their
scriptures by Mohammad to give this kind
of discipline to wife to keep them in
check this is why they got to walk
several feet behind them they're like
lower than animals they're just trust me
you don't want to live in you don't want
to live if you're one of my friend where
like than animals
Muslim 22 let me know when you finish
all right now I
I everybody come down everybody come
down I think you little brainwashed
about how they treat about the
woman it's it's okay it's okay it's okay
it's okay so look you wanted to see
Muhammad right so look this is what
Muhammad says this is a this Abu da 2146
it's a it's aith it's sah great sah that
means it's authentic okay so look this
is what it says so it says um um uh Le
bin
Abdullah Abu duab reported Allah's
Messenger as saying do not beat Allah's
handmaidens your wives but when Umar
came to the
messenger of Allah and said women have
become emboldened towards their husbands
the prophet gave permission to beat them
wow wow so what is this is a Hadith yes
it's it's a Hadith and it's Hadith by
who it's a by AB so AB so we we we
Muslims believe more
like yeah you all of that there there's
six of
you is one of the six books that you
guys follow this exactly same thing you
know like what I'm talking about you can
get interpret whatever you want brother
this is this is
sah a sah but uh it's a lot of Hadi you
know like it's authentic we can't we
can't go against this but like uh this
what I'm saying we we follow more more
like Sahari you you follow Abu da too
that's one of you look you got exactly
I'm not like I'm not that religious
person to argue with you
okay what we doing over here yeah I'm
like a super religious person like you
or I'm not religious I just want to
debate you for an hour but but yeah
exactly you know be I'm just I'm just
I'm just talking to you guys having
conversation it's a good
conversation I don't have a like it's
argue with you I I'm telling you I never
read the finish the Quran yeah I got you
God forgive me you know you're look look
this what I say okay look I'm here stay
talking having conversation I'm not
arguing nothing which which I appreciate
you coming through you listened you know
you had a conversation you engaged which
I appreciate so this what I will leave
this guy is going really angry I don't
know no you're not
angry just he's just passionate he just
passionate he's just passionate but look
this is where this is where we're at
guys this is where we're at one refer my
love to you yeah that's right he loves
you brother so look this is where we're
at as Christians right we follow the
word of God the Bible which as you know
the Quran says God sent the problem with
that is that the Quran contradict the
Bible and so therefore the Quran can't
be true if it says the Bible is true and
contradicts
it I'm listen I'm listen Okay that's
that's one I want to just summarize what
we went over okay so that's that's the
most important right who the Messiah is
you got to go to the Bible who the
Messiah is we see that he's the Divine
Son of God Who Came In the Flesh right
came in human form if you're saying that
he's the Messiah then you're in trouble
in Islam right cuz obviously the Quran
contradicts that that's two three
obviously you're how the Quran and and
Muhammad says you can treat women it
says if you fear Disobedience you can
beat them and Muhammad himself gave
permission to beat your wives if they
are too bold with you so these are the
issues that I have with the Quran and
Islam so again
sir
alhamdulillah alhamdulillah
Jesus is
King Jesus is King Jesus is
king oh my God logic
oh